oh look at that smooth transition [ __ ]
going on you smelly ass sexy ass hmm
practices practice talking to yourself
into a camera I don't know if a lot of
people out there realize that just
talking to a camera like a crazy person
it's not the easiest thing to do my
neighbors so on Wednesday on Twitter I
said that I was going to announce
something special
it's Thursday now and I forgot to
announce something special as you guys
know I have been been doing this whole
podcast thing for a minute and I'm
probably going to continue to do this
podcasting for quite a while and the big
news that I wanted to share with you
guys and obviously you saw the clickbait
because its clickbait
I'm leaving JK news at first I wasn't
going to make a huge announcement about
it and I was just going to slowly fade
out and I've talked about this with Bart
and Jo but talking with Jess she kind of
asked me to address this in a certain
way because people kind of go crazy with
the comments so the reason why I'm
leaving JK news is because I [ __ ]
hate the platform I'm kidding yes what
you want to hear you little sick [ __ ] no
I'm not leaving JK news because
something bad happened between me Bart
Jo Jo and the rest of the crew I work
still [ __ ] great the reason why I'm
leaving JK news is because it's time for
me to grow the [ __ ] up listen I've been
a part of JK news for a very long time
actually since the very first episode
and since it first started so if you
guys want to go into a little bit of
story time let me just tell you how JK
and you started up now you might have
heard this on the podcast but I'm just
gonna give you guys a little more
insight Jay King you started up it was
just literally parking-lot conversation
when me Bart Joe and the rest of the
crew would hang out we would just end up
at a parking lot just shooting [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] time and then barn joe was
like well instead of us just sitting
around in a parking lot just
bullshitting for two to three hours we
might as well just record and see if
people buy with it and lo and behold JK
news was born I've been varus's the very
first episode and we've all garnered a
lot of success from doing this channel
but for me and you guys already know
this about me I I like to I don't know
move on from things now for a while it
was hard for me to lead JK news because
number one it was fun like I liked
hanging out
my friends I like talking [ __ ] and just
making people laugh and I just really
enjoy all the conversations but one of
the bigger reasons was it was it was it
was difficult to have guests on the show
now if you guys remember on JK news back
in the day we would have guests and you
know the comments would rip in and then
they'd like why did you even bring this
guest on they have no opinions they're
not even saying anything and I think
it's because the vibe that we have on
this channel is number one we could give
a [ __ ] less and number two we could give
a [ __ ] less it's very hard to find
youtubers I believe that are
unapologetic and aren't afraid to speak
their mind and so when they would come
on to the JK new space they would lock
up and freeze up because they you know
what if I say this and what if people
rip into me and say this a majority of
us don't care and especially if you see
me on that channel I could give a [ __ ]
less what anybody thinks about me
Oh David your [ __ ] stories are fake
Oh David you think you're such a tough
guy I don't give a [ __ ] then go say that
[ __ ] to my face and if you did I would
slap the living [ __ ] out of you
depending on your size your weight if
your buff or if you've been in print
there's a lot of okay well let's just
move on from this so but now it's time
for me to grow up and move on um JK news
is a very comfortable spot for me it's
something that I enjoy I like a little
too much to the point where I'm doing it
just to do it and there are so many
things that I should be doing and
focusing on but instead of putting the
time to develop my career and where I
want to go is specifically you know with
this you know send blue stuff that I'm
doing on Thrillist and all this other
writing stuff I'm complacent and hanging
out with my friends all the time and for
me instead of putting time into things
that I'm doing such as my channel that
I've neglected I I decide just to hang
out with my friends on that platform and
it's it's not good for me it's great for
fun times and it makes me happy but now
it's time for me to really focus on
myself right you know there's a few
stockpile videos where I will be on JK
news but for probably after like a month
or two I probably won't be popping up on
that channel anymore and if you want to
see me come onto the genius brain
podcast where come onto my channel and
this is where I'm going to reside I'm
back on YouTube baby and I'm not saying
that I'm gonna do a weekly video except
for the you know the podcast stuff the
podcast stuff will be up every Thursday
and Sunday but now I'm gonna come back
to my platform and just really work on
my social media game man but I'm here
and I hope you're ready for some new
content
I said I'm not gonna give you guys a
specific time just keep those
notification bells on and you're gonna
have some really dope and fun videos so
yes me Bart Joe Gio everybody else to
rest accrued you know Tiff's were all
great terms
nothing was sad it was just more like
they understood and I understand my
point of view they get it and now I
won't be on JK news anymore men just
still watch that channel it's amazing
and if you want to see me talk my [ __ ]
just come to this place number one I
love my fans on this channel if you are
a JK News hater and you come onto my
channel I will block the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of you
number two you ain't [ __ ] I literally
hope that one day you find somebody that
you love they swindle you for all the
money that you have your children grow
up hating you and your penis falls off
continue to watch day I can use continue
to watch JK news it's super funny
they're gonna have a lot of great
rotating guests and now that they have a
flow that works without me I'm super
happy to say that I can comfortably
leave the J can use a platform and start
doing my own [ __ ] again uh that's about
it guys that's the announcement nothing
crazy but just get ready for some random
videos on this channel baby oh and
before I leave I should do the youtuber
thing like comment subscribe and you
know let me know stuff that you want to
see I'm gonna be creating some very
interesting videos because I don't know
I'm getting excited to shoot again
so yeah just you know like comments guy